we really believe that that there is a
gap in the market of having a jazz 1q
sr1
restaurant chain a both great quality
coffee but at the same time baked
products and food again that's one of
the reasons why we do believe that the
level of success that we are going to be
having here is very big on top of that
we believe that we have we are
partnering here with one of the best
operators in the country that's SKU SK
Group which is a great partner that has
a lot of experience in terms of
operations and with those two things
great product great value and a great
operator and a great team we really
believe that we will be very successful
also in a great return
starting by Glasgow okay but you're up
again Starbucks coaster eat cafe Nero
and lots of others and they are way
ahead of you how are you going to catch
up persistence delivering the best
brother the best value and continuing to
be doing that restaurant after
restaurant and making sure that we
develop a good density over time we
really believe that by delivering that
great product great value we will be
catching option how much will a cup of
coffee cost me one of your outlets 119
okay so cheaper than cheaper than
coaster or Starbucks is that the
magnified great value I wouldn't say
cheaper definitely great value for the
quality of the product that we have at
the price that we are selling it okay so
you start seeing clothes go white gloves
go very simple we did a lot of research
in terms of of the word to open in great
return first and we saw that the
demographics and the consumer here in
this market was exactly exactly looking
for that looking for for the three
qualities at the same time Coffee Bay
products AB food at a great value and
that was reason number one reason number
two for historical reasons there is a
great brand awareness from from Stratos
and a great deal between Scotland and
Canada and by the way interesting time
to be coming
the UK economy we've got brexit in less
than two years time what do you make of
that we really believe in this market
and we really believe in the opportunity
that this product and this great brand
that has been successful in Canada and
in the US and now also opening in Middle
East and in Philippines is going to be
having in the market that's why we came
and we are very very very consistent in
the opinion of believing that we we will
succeed here and follow though is I've
had coffee in North America and I've had
lots of coffee here in the UK it's not
always the same product have you had to
change your offer for the British coffee
drinker we have adapt your front to the
to the British consumer but Danny coffee
same absolutely same coffee
absolutely same quality and bringing
exactly the same offer from that
perspective we have strengthened
obviously our Latta an espresso platform
here in the market that same product